the libs have indicted Trump again this
one's a little different this one is not
at the federal level this is not
overdranuary 6th the worst in the
history of the world this is not over an
in-kind campaign contribution from some
tabloid story in New York this is over a
phone call that Trump had after the
Democrats rigged the election and he
called Georgia and he said hey what's
going on in Georgia where are the votes
uh that phone call now has gotten him
and his lawyers and all sorts of people
indicted the other big difference
between this indictment and the other
seven thousand indictments that they've
thrown at him before is that in this
case the authorities are promising to
take a mug shot We are following our
part out our normal practices and so it
doesn't matter your status we have
mugshots ready for it look at that
little smirk that little smirk on the
Gestapo there at the end oh I don't know
it doesn't matter we're going to take a
mug shot this time yeah and we're going
to get your Trump